[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one wall that matters and
it is here
hey guys Pete here it's going to be my
Game of Thrones season 7 episode 7
season finale trailer breakdown so it's
kind of a short trailer not a lot of
words spoken but a lot of looks given
and I think what's really the most
telling part of this is the things that
we don't see we know everyone's headed
to King's Landing to show Queen Cersei
the white and the threat from the north
and the first thing that you notice that
we don't see is Daenerys and all the
different scenes that we see people
coming in and getting arranged in the
dragon pit there she's clearly not with
her people which obviously leads to the
idea that she's going to make a grand
entrance on dragon back I think that's
pretty cool and the other thing that we
don't see in this trailer is we don't
see anything north of the wall which is
also probably a harbinger of the fact
that something big is going to go down
there and they don't want to tip their
hat that big thing is probably a breach
of the wall either the wall falling or
something along those lines but they're
not giving us any hints in the trailer
so I'm going to go through and do a
frame by frame and then we'll talk about
what all this stuff means it is going to
be the longest episode of Game of
Thrones of all time 81 minutes so that
means there's going to be a lot of stuff
that's going to happen that we don't see
in this trailer at all so we start off
with a shot of grey worm we see the
unsullied in formation in the field
outside of King's Landing we get a
couple aerial shots we see the Dothraki
come in for a grand entrance
showing the contrast between the two
different types of soldiers involved
here and Daenerys is army we see the
iron fleet outside in the bay and then
we catch a shot of Tyrion on deck with
Varys and Theon and the look on Tyrion
face says it all really it's not a great
situation they can't be excited about
going into the Lions Den if you will but
this
is the path that they chose and they
should know that Daenerys is on her way
to meet them there and to basically burn
everything up if [ __ ] gets out of hand
we also see Jaime and Bronn up on top of
the wall watching the Dothraki come in
there look pretty much says it all -
they're seeing that this is a formidable
army that they've already faced down
once I was wondering when this shot was
going to come up because we saw this
during the filming and they actually
didn't do these in Croatia so we thought
this might be at Highgarden originally
but they are there they're watching the
armies come in and they're also on edge
like everyone should be we get our one
shot of the north and it's Sansa
she's up on top of the walls at
Winterfell we can see that winter is
definitely there the weather looks cold
and snowy she sort of has her eyes
closed at first appears to be deep in
thought which is pretty common in all of
the trailers for Game of Thrones when
you think about it and she takes a walk
after doing something we can't tell at
all what it is but she's probably
thinking about the situation between
Littlefinger and her sister Arya we see
that shot again a Theon dropping to one
knee on the beach seems a little bit out
of place because we had seen him
traveling the drinking's Landing with
Tyrion this has to be something that
happens before they go but there's
really no clues here as to what that
might be from there there is a sequence
of shots we see Cersei emerge from her
chambers we see the king in the north
being led in embarrasses there Tyrians
with him we get the shots of each of
them sort of squaring up in the dragon
pit this is the dragon pit in case you
weren't sure where they are it's in
King's Landing we see just about
everyone who's here we see Dror there we
see Davos we do not see the white though
and we also don't see the Hound in any
of these shots but I'm gonna go ahead
and make a connection there because he's
probably going to be the one that brings
him in we don't see the mountain but we
know he's there he's the head of Circe's
Kingsguard or Queens guard I guess in
this case so we know he won't
far away they could be trying to make
some false cooking bowl Heights by not
showing either one of them but I do
believe they'll both be there sir sneeze
putting on a face of looking like she's
confident which I guess that's what she
should do although what's the nearest
lands I mean she's really not in that
strong of a position in her own house
when you think about it we don't see any
hint of any of the other armies we don't
really know what else is going on as far
as that's concerned but pretty much all
the major players of our main story are
there we don't see her on inside the
dragon pit either he may show up no word
of yarra for quite a few episodes either
tom says the only words in the trailer
and he says there is only one lure that
matters and it is here and we're able to
assume that this is where they bring in
the white and Cersei and Jaime get to
see it firsthand so yeah there's not a
lot going on in this trailer that we
wouldn't be anticipating already so
there's a lot to speculate about what
they left out and why they left it out I
think it's just a pretty clear strategy
to get us thinking about things and
going to typed up about what might
happen I mean this is the biggest
meeting of characters of ever I mean
think about it most of these characters
haven't been in the scene together and
now they're all here we're going to see
Daenerys Cersei Jaime Jon Snow Tyrion
and the list just goes on and on these
people are all going to be together and
considering that this is an 80-minute
episode and there's little other stuff
that I can imagine that's going to be
happening there's going to be a pretty
it's going to be pretty awesome we don't
really have any idea how the whole
presentation of the white will go but it
should be pretty impressive to everyone
involved considering how we see all the
pieces laid out in what their relative
position is you have to imagine that
Cersei is going to agree with Jon Snow
that this is a real threat but you have
to also imagine that she might not be
able to be trusted here like I said we
don't see any of the other army so we
don't really even know what she has to
give towards this thing of going north
and because they haven't shown anything
with the night king and the night king
has a newly turn dragon I'm expecting
that something big will happen up there
at the wall that's going to be the
cliffhanger and then we're going to have
to spend the next year however long it
takes
wondering how everything is going to
develop who's left up north while we
know that torment is obviously there and
barek seems to have stayed behind
everyone else I think has returned not
sure if they all came to King's Landing
but it's a pretty good guess that they
did scenario shows up with the dragon
possibly - what do you guys think is
going to happen I don't really think the
game Bowl is going to happen I think
that the two will see each other Sandor
is on a different path now and Cersei
certainly wouldn't have been like okay
with it if he tried to kill her main
protector so I don't think that's going
to happen I think there'll be a lot of
dialogue I think there'll be a lot of
interesting stuff the fact that Cersei
destroyed the set may come into the play
but that might just be a reminder
everyone that there's probably wildfire
all throughout the city underneath it
Tyrion obviously knows about that - let
me know what you guys think what are you
excited for what do you think is going
to happen how are they going to stretch
this into 81 minutes please like the
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel and set notifications if
you haven't yet got a bunch of videos
bonus videos coming out this week about
what's going to happen in the end game
of the show so you'll want to check back
for those make sure you follow me on
Twitter Instagram Facebook you can get
interacting with me over there thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one war that matters and
it is here